لحظات كشفت مداه هشاشه المباني في المناطق
المتضرره من زلزال تركيا والسلطات تحاول
احتواء الغضب الشعبي في هذه المناطق قوات
الامن نفذت حمله اعتقالات طالت عشرات
المقاولين والمهندسين واعلن وزير العدل
التركي بكير بوزداج انشاء مكتب للتحقيق في
جرائم الزلزال وما تبعه من وفيات واصابات
كما كشف الوزير عن اعتقال 62 من مقاولي
البناء فيما قالت وكاله انباء الاناضول ان
عدد المعتقلين تجاوز المئه في المقاطعات
العشره التي طالها الزلزال
تركيا سبق لها ان شددت قوانين البناء بعد
زلزال ازميت شمال غرب البلاد عام
1999 والذي قتل فيه 17 الف شخص المعايير
التي تم تحديثها عام 2018 تستلزم استخدام
هياكل مصنوعه من خرسانه عاليه الجوده
مدعمه بقضبان فولاذيه وعلى ان توزع
الاعمده لامتصاص تاثير الزلازل بشكل فعال
لكن رغم المعايير المفروضه قدمت السلطات
اعفاءات للمباني المنشاه دون شهادات
السلامه المطلوبه على ان يتم دفع رسوم
مقابل عدم الالتزام الاعفاءات هذه لقيه
انتقادات داخليه وحذر منتقدون من ان
التهاون في قوانين البناء قد يؤدي لكارثه
حال وقوع زلزال كبير في الجانب البحري
نقلت صحيفه حريات ديلين نيوز عن استاد
جيولوجيا بجامعه اسطنبول قوله ان اختيار
اماكن البناء جرى بشكل غير علمي مست جدا
بزلزال كايكور نيوزلنديه عام 2016 الذي
بلغت قوته 7.8 درجه وادى حينها لمقتل
شخصين واصابه سبعه وخمسين اخرين